the game is changing i know i come with
a history not all of you love i'm not
gonna get edged out
[Music]
the game is changing
my job is to ensure the stability of uba
alex i need you to come back you are the
only thing that can save us
i don't think i've ever said that before
i'm not gonna get edged out alex levy
i feel like i'm bringing in my big
sister to clean up my mess man you
couldn't have planned this any better
stepping away when you did
i was broken doug
yeah
ratings have been down this network
needs to clean up its act five try and
get ahead of this corona virus four
someone should cover it well bradley can
do it three don't forget this is your
show and we're back two i know i come
with a history that not all of you love
one nine months ago you opened a door
and you need to walk through it now
a bombshell from journalist maggie
brenner's upcoming expose on the behind
the scenes troubles at uba's the morning
show
there is a pattern of behavior around
here that disadvantages the people of
color we need to get our facts straight
we need to decide what the truth is did
you hear what you just said
maggie i would like to see the book you
don't like me you've never liked me
that's not true
which part
onward and upward
you're a dynamo out there i don't think
they're using you in the right way i
don't trust her she seems perfectly nice
[Music]
oh catch me
i'm your boss i'm gonna make sure it
works out oh you're my boss i thought
you were my friend i'm on your side the
network doesn't think you have the it
factor we're looking to showcase some
other talent you know what the problem
with racism is you don't fix it by
pretending to want to fix it
what i want is to change things because
the jury's still out if you were
successful
happy days are here again
[Music]
in case you forgot i'm the whistleblower
i'm gonna get everything i want
you're just so caught up in ruling over
your rotten little fiefdom
the rest of the world they've moved to
the cloud and it is gorgeous up there
[Music]
this is a battle for the soul of the
universe
[Music]
[Music]
you